okay we're finally ready to build the
common filter okay so the common filter
is basically the analog of the linear
quadratic regulator for estimation it's
the optimal full state estimator given
some knowledge about the types of
disturbances and types of measurement
noise that I'm going to experience okay
so in practice we're going to assume
that WD is a Gaussian white noise
process so Gaussian white noise process
with variance let's call it V so let's
say it's variance is V D and this is
going to be lets say covariance so this
will be a square matrix of size n by n
okay so however many states I have this
will be yeah for disturbance it will be
an N by n matrix and then let's say that
W n is also Gaussian so this is the
first one is my disturbance the second
one is my noise and it also has some
noise covariance some V n variance and
so basically if I think that my process
noise the kicks that my system is going
to experience are larger or smaller than
the noise that my measurement has then I
get to trust one or the other more than
more so remember my common filter is
measuring U and Y and it has a model it
has a model of a B and C but if it has
really bad sensor noise it can't trust Y
very much so it has to rely on its model
more but if it has really really big
disturbances if it can get kicked way
off where it thinks it is then it should
trust its measurements why more so this
there's some reason to think that based
on the ratio of these these
various matrices if I have bigger
disturbances than noise then I should
trust my measurements and if I have
bigger noise than disturbances I should
trust my model okay and so there's this
balance of how remember we had we we
found that we can essentially write the
error of our prediction equals a minus
Coleman filter C times error okay so we
could essentially make this error we
could make our estimate X hat converge
arbitrarily quickly to X remember error
was just X minus X hat we could make
this thing converge arbitrarily quickly
by choosing the Coleman filter Gaines to
make this very stable very negative
eigenvalues but again just like in the
lqr case in real life I'm constantly
balancing how much noise I have on my
measurements and how much disturbances I
have in my system so there will be a
sweet spot for these eigenvalues too and
in fact they max they minimize a cost
function J which is essentially the
expectation value of X minus X hat the
column vector X minus X hat and I'm
pretty sure this is transpose times X
minus X hat and so this is a little bit
more tricky to picture but basically if
I had an ensemble of different
disturbances and noise is sampled from
these distributions then I'd want to
choose this common filter gain to
minimize the expected error between my
state my full state and my estimate okay
and it doesn't look like it but this can
be written in a form that's almost
identical to this lqr cost function and
so in fact I can use the exact same
linear algebra guts that I used to solve
for this gain matrix K regulator I can
use the same linear algebra to search to
solve for this column and filter gains
KF and in particular we saw
something called an algebraic riccati
equation to find these gains again it's
order n cubed in the state dimension of
X but for moderately you know the size
systems its tractable and we can do that
and then you can get these optimal
common filter gains for your full state
estimator so in MATLAB it's pretty
simple I think it's something like K F
equals lq e so now remember we use lqr
for the quadratic regulator full state
control this is a linear quadratic
estimator so lq e is basically
synonymous with calm and filter I do lqe
of a C and then you know V I forget if
it's BD and then VN or what the order is
that you can look at the help file but
basically these now serve the role of
the Q and the are matrices in lqr
for this this column and filter design
okay so very very similar you can
actually a good exercise I would
recommend you try try to develop these
calm and filter games using the lqr
command use the fact that there is a
duality between a B and a C and try to
massage this so you can actually use
this lqr command to solve the algebraic
riccati equation to get this common
filter okay so I'm not going to go as
much into the analysis of this I think
what we should do is try it out on an
example where we have a full state but
we're only measuring one or two
variables and see if we can design a
common filter to estimate what the full
system is actually doing okay